hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll so as
I'm recording this I recently was
reading an article by Clive Thompson on
the effect that the covid pandemic has
had on education and the fact of course
there's a whole thing where students go
to school for couldn't go to school for
a while and people had to learn remotely
but what about not University students
but lower levels high school and
secondary school students well it turns
out the effect of the pandemic was bad
on education here in the United States
uh for sure and that's maybe not
surprising you know a lot of the
resources a lot of the usual ways that
we did things just weren't available
even if we could have found ways that
were just as good it takes time to do
that and so certain students are really
hurt by that but interestingly the
decline in scores which is sort of
across the board is much higher in math
than it is in Reading
so for whatever reason there was a much
bigger deleterious effect of
homeschooling on kids trying to learn
math than kids trying to learn reading
and why is that and in the essay tries
to argue that it's basically because
when you're at home and you're trying to
learn math you're going to learn it from
your parents and chances are good that
your parents hate math because a lot of
people hate math it's it's considered
okay to hate math to say oh I'm not so
good at math I don't really understand
that stuff it's too hard in a way that
it's not considered okay to hate reading
or or history or other forms of
knowledge and that's a weird thing and
it's probably a bad thing and one of the
people in the world who's done the most
to combat this feeling is today's guest
John Allen Pelos famously he's the
author of innumeracy mathematical
literacy and his consequences that's
back in 1988 but he's a mathematician at
Temple University and he's kept kept up
this fight to get people to overcome
their enumeracy their mathematical
illiteracy and to learn more to be more
comfortable learning math including in a
brand new book called who's counting
uniting numbers and narratives with
stories from pop culture puzzles
politics and more in the podcast we're
going to talk a little bit about math
but largely in some sense we're talking
about the relationship between Ordinary
People and math what is the math that
people should know how should we teach
it to them why don't they want to learn
it why why is it so frightening is it is
it their fault is it our fault for how
we teach it how could we do better but
then we also do talk a little about the
the substance of math because it's not
just that we need to teach math and need
to get better at it but what kinds of
math should we teach and I think that
there's a thing that is said over and
over again in my circles that we
actually don't spend nearly enough time
teaching probability and statistics to
people of all sorts of backgrounds
whether you're going to be a
professional scientist or whether you're
just going to be doing anything else in
the world there's a knowledge of
probability that is very very helpful
that somehow we do not successfully
convey to people in the educational
system so we talk a little about
conditional probabilities and how you
can get an intuition for things like
that and and why math works at all and
how it can be uh conveyed using jokes
and humor which makes everything a
little bit better so I think this is
kind of an important topic I'm not sure
that we solved it once and for all but
paying attention to it is one step in
the right direction
occasional reminder that here at
mindscape we have a patreon feed go to
patreon.com Sean M Carroll and you can
get both ad free episodes and the
ability to contribute to the ask me
anything questions that we have and yet
another uh occasional reminder that we
have the mindscape big picture
scholarship it's been going very very
well I think we're going to be able to
give out three College scholarships this
year of ten thousand dollars each so if
you go to
bold.org scholarships mindscape you can
either contribute to it if you're at
that stage of your life or apply for it
if you're at that stage of your life so
I'm looking forward to seeing what the
winners are going to be and what great
things they're going to do and with that
let's go
[Music]
thank you
John Allen polis welcome to the my skate
podcast it's a pleasure to be here Sean
so you've in some sense maybe you tell
me this is fair or not but in some sense
you've devoted your life to fighting
against enumeracy or maybe you want to
say two-promoting numeracy you wrote a
wonderful book with the title innumeracy
how do you yourself Define numeracy or
enumeracy
uh I think University is just the
ability to deal reasonably well with
numbers probabilities logic uh so
there's no hard and fast uh precise
definition but uh uh and then numeracy
of course uh is uh an inability to deal
with basic numbers basic probability
basic logic I mean and uh again it's uh
it's one of one of the points I like to
make over again is the dubiousness of
precision and uh so I you know people
are very precise and the Precision is
unwarranted so um that's my defense for
not giving a more precise definition
no that's completely fair I think I
guess the reason why I'm wondering is
because I'm thinking about literacy
which is the obvious comparison and in
some sense literacy is more of a yes no
question you know some people have
bigger vocabularies than others but but
you read or you don't whereas when it
comes to math there's just seem to be a
Continuum like I I know a lot of math
I've I've learned a lot I use it all the
time I still feel there's enormously
more math than I don't know than what I
know
well I think that to some extent that's
still the case with uh with literacy I
mean people who can you know read the
newspaper you give them a book by you
know I don't know Heidegger yeah or even
even a normal person reading a book by a
Hydra uh would uh it would be uh baffled
so there is kind of a Continuum although
it's a little bit more binary with
literacy than it is with numeracy and I
think that uh but there are different
kinds of mathematical knowledge I think
that maybe some people who are not into
the world of math maybe don't appreciate
what mathematicians do for a living
versus calculating you know like what I
do I I'm no better at calculating a tip
or doing my taxes than anybody else's I
don't know about you yeah now it's the
same
[Laughter]
sorry what so what is how do you think
about that difference how do you think
about math as opposed to just
multiplying and dividing
Point I've made in a couple of my books
is that uh meth is much greater than
computation well that's most people it's
kind of myopic view of it but math is to
uh computation and its literature is to
typing nobody says uh you're a great
typist why don't you write a novel or
Converse and so
you know that's why one of the obstacles
to uh in teaching math people think they
know it already I know how to multiply I
know how to plug form it was into
numbers into formulas is there something
more but there's a lot more I mean
patterns logic uh structure of various
sorts and that uh you know it maps on to
Everyday events often enough that uh
it's it's worth knowing even if you're
not going to be a mathematician even
among mathematicians I find that people
who are analysts often don't understand
some what I think is an obvious point in
probability of statistics of people who
are in in algebraic topology don't
necessarily understand much about phonak
spaces and yeah but that's the case with
a lot of things I mean my my son's a
lawyer and uh you know whenever my wife
or I have a question we know not to ask
him because he's a very good lawyer he
makes a lot of money but he only knows
what he knows right yeah it's
specialized
let me let me just let's get some
examples on the table so people have an
idea of what we're talking about in the
book like right right at the beginning
you say the following thing if at least
one of a woman's two children is a boy
born in the summer
the probability she has two boys is 7
15.
all right
well let me know if the
affiliate woman has two sons if the uh
given well probability two sons given
she's got at least one son that's
one-third because you can't have uh girl
girls so probability two boys giving at
least one boy is one-third the
probability of uh
uh two boys giving at least one boy born
in the summer
is 7 15 which is which is close to a
half
so it's uh that the more precise you are
about I mean you can set up the sample
space and uh convince yourself but the
more process precise you are about uh
the The Voice she does have that has two
boys at least one of whom is born on
July 4th
uh then the probability is almost a half
so the more I mean it's hard without
like writing out the sample space but
it's typical of uh problems and many
problems in probability they're
counterintuitive that's one reason
people have problems with uh probability
they're they're they're
probabilistic vocabulary is limited to
one in a million maybe or 50 50 or sure
thing
and uh on top of that they people don't
think naturally in terms of probability
and many people oh everything has a
reason and uh and the fact that
propositions like you just mentioned are
counter-intuitive they're the most
famous example is the birthday uh puzzle
of 23 people sufficient for uh if you
have 23 people in the room at
probability is uh one half that at least
two have the same birthday
well that's why I wanted to discuss this
example in particular because that even
the number 7 15 is maybe not you know I
don't really care what that number is
this is not going to come up very often
but it's an example of conditional
probability of you know probability of
one thing and how it changes given some
extra information I mean is that
something that people struggle with
especially in your experience
uh yeah uh conditional probability we're
revising one's uh probability
probability estimates is something we do
in everyday life the only thing is in if
you study probability or Bayes rule in
particular you can refine it so all
everything we do in probability in a
sense are refinements of Notions that
develop naturally I mean the notion of
uh me meeting and mode or central
tendency to all kinds of words in
English or other natural languages at
average so so
uh whatever a complex of words that
essentially mean 50 50 or the mean
average the same thing with variance
there's all kinds of words in English
that elderly natural language is too far
out uh disparate very different far out
is interesting because it's far out on a
distribution
and uh the same thing with with uh
probability I mean a small year
commented people generally have been uh
you know speaking prose all their life
and they're generally been speaking
probability all their life it's just
that they speak with a very bad accent I
mean a simple example in Bayes theorem
if you have two coins and one of them is
two-headed one of them is fair you don't
know which is which you pick one up and
flip it three times you get three heads
in a row any you know it's common sense
to say well it's very likely
more likely that she picked a two-headed
coin but but only base theorem says that
that probability rises from one half to
eight ninths so as I said the
probability statistics are refinements
or distillations of kind of hazy
nebulous everyday
uh Notions
well the classic example of this that uh
Royal I guess it wasn't the internet
I've seen before the internet was around
but the Monty Hall problem got people
very worked up right why don't you
remind us of what the Monty Hall problem
is because maybe there's still people
out there who never heard of it
yeah there are actually at least my
experience the Monty Hall problem has to
do with uh the TV show a number of years
ago Let's Make a Deal in which there's a
host and a guest and three doors behind
one of which is a car
and the host asks the guests to choose
the door behind which he hopes is a new
car and if he's correct he gets a new
car so that's a uh the guest picks door
one
then the host who knows where the car is
always opens one of the one of the other
doors where he's it's certain that
there's no car so he always opens a door
behind which there's nothing
and then he actually posted against you
are you sure you don't want to switch uh
from one to two let's say he opens door
three you sure you don't want to switch
from one to two you you chose door one
I've opened door three you want to
switch your your bet to two
and uh often people say no it doesn't
make any difference there's two doors
open chances are uh 50 50 one-half that
I might as well stay here yeah but he
should switch because the probability he
was right the first time is one-third
the probability uh the car is behind one
of the other two doors is two-thirds but
since uh the host opens door three that
two-thirds probability is now focused on
the unopened door so worry to switch he
would raise his probability of winning
the car from one third to two-thirds but
um many people including them there's a
story that may be apocryphal but the
great Paul Erdos a mathematician was
supposedly baffled by this I found that
I find it hard to believe myself too
yeah
but but I mean maybe I don't because the
way that you stated the problem
everything made super duper perfect
sense I I do think that sometimes when
people State problems like this they
kind of want people to get the wrong
answer just to you know explain the
trickiness of it so they they kind of
hide that fact that Monty Hall will only
ever open the door where the car is not
there right and that does change the
problem
does change the problem I mean it's one
thing I tell my students in a to and
probability your math in general being
really clear about what you're saying is
very important in fact yesterday I asked
my class I said if you killed a coin a
thousand times what's the most likely
number of heads you get and two is that
a likely number of heads to get and of
course 500 is the most likely number of
heads
and no it's not very likely as you're
going to get 500 hits
what I try to do is you know show the
relevance of puzzles uh the puzzles I do
talk about to everyday life so I imagine
a
dual game in which instead of Monty Hall
there's this psychopath there called
taunty Hall and and there's a guest and
the same thing the only thing is if he
picks the door The crucial door there's
not a car there there's a little gun
that shoots out a toxic mist of gas and
sickens the person choosing that door so
again the the person picks the door
let's say pick store one tonti Hall
always opens the door behind which he
knows there's nothing and say he opens
three and then he asks yes do you want
to switch to door too
and uh now he should say no because for
the same reason he was right one third
of the time two-thirds of the
probability of the other two doors but
he wants to limit his exposure so he
should stick there so it's a kind of
dual problem you should stick with what
he picked and you know uh you know the
relevant to that let's say to covet is
you want to limit the number of people
you've come in contact with I mean
they're versions of this with a hundred
doors or whatever but um
in any case and did you do I remember in
the book you you claim I might be
completely misremming this but people
are better at getting that version of
the problem right than the original
Monty Hall problem I I think they are I
mean maybe fear is uh induces one to
think more clearly than those uh it's
agreed I'm not sure although greed does
a good job too greed does a pretty good
job but I think it's actually I mean
maybe it's just not about thinking
clearly right you know I I pretty firmly
believe that the human brain was not
evolved and optimized to do math
problems but there's sort of situations
we find ourselves in that are analogous
to math problems that we are that our
brain is pretty good at and maybe being
scared of something is closer to that
instinctual correctness than uh looking
out for a reward
yeah I think that's true I mean you
don't know A Primitive man didn't need
uh probability to realize if there's a
rustling in the bush to to run
to be launched a lot of the time it's
interesting because I've been thinking
for various reasons both teaching and
research about the arrow of time and the
second law of Thermodynamics recently
and reading back in the history of it or
even hearing what modern physics
professors tell their students that
there's this issue that came up in the
1870s about the number of ways a system
can go from low entropy to high entropy
versus the number it can go from high
entropy to low entropy and the the
answer is the num those two numbers have
to be exactly the same because the
underlying there's a symmetry of
reversibility of the underlying system
and lo Schmidt famously made this
objection to boltzmann but there's
plenty of textbooks you can read that
will tell you no it's there's more ways
to go from low entropy to high than high
to low and they're making the same
mistake about conditional probabilities
I think they're they're conditionalizing
on starting in low entropy which is a
big cheat
uh yeah no that that's an interesting
point yeah that's that's true actually
there's one uh kind of political
instance of
thermodynamics for lack of a better term
and and that's uh Baldini's principle
that it's much much easier or sometimes
called the [ __ ] principle much
easier to produce [ __ ] than it is to
refuted
and right Mark Twain had a similar
comment he said it's much easier to con
people than it is to convince them
they've been conned oh yeah right people
don't want to believe that
yeah okay I mean so Q Anon conspiracy
theorists the election deniers I mean
once they publicly State the nonsense
they believe that it's very hard to get
them back
well you've talked in this book and
elsewhere a lot about pseudoscience and
conspiracy theories and and so forth
what is the connection to numeracy or
innumeracy there
well I think uh it's just clear thinking
there in in that case I mean uh you've
got to know some facts you've got to
know a modicum of arithmetic probability
and if you don't uh you're more easily
um
and more easily pulled I mean like the
prosecutor's Paradox uh is relevant
again to to uh conditional probability
uh there's some crime and there's a lot
of evidence and you they arrest somebody
if that person's innocent the
probability of the evidence that he was
around the the murder he did have big
shoes he did talk to people around there
so the probability of that evidence
given he's innocent is low but that's
not the relevant conditional probability
right the relevant condition of
probability is the probability he's
innocent given the evidence and the
defense attorney will bring in all the
other people who have these
characteristics and the probability of
Innocence given evidence is much higher
often than the probability of evidence
given innocence but it's very easy of
people
don't understand about conditional
probability or just conditional
statements that don't know the
difference between if a then B and if B
then a which is basically what
conditional probability is and this kind
of feeds in with in the case of the
conspiracy theories uh some kind of
wishful thinking right or some kind of
search for clarity in a simple system
that covers everything and and so maybe
this is an example where human
psychology and bad math work hand in
hand to lead people to wrong conclusions
oh that's definitely the case in fact
cognitive foibles in general are a big
part of what leads people astray and
we're all uh vulnerable to them the
anchoring effect
availability error confirmation advice
one that doesn't get as much publicity
as the conjunction fallacy you have
somebody that says a Senator U.S senator
and he's everybody you know he's very
moderate he's uh intelligent uh
you know rectitude is a word that comes
to mind for everybody thinks of him he
lives modestly with a wife and his
daughter who's unfortunately very sick
but in any case given that background
what's more likely that this Senator
took a bribe from a lobbyist
or that he took a ride from a lobbyist
and used the money to pay for his
daughter's expensive operation right and
most people say well or at least a lot
of people uh probably the latter given
what she said about him but it's more
likely that he took money from a
lobbyist period because it's always
easier to satisfy one condition than two
or more conditions and what that has to
do with the internet and fake news
is given the internet all kinds of odd
facts factoids uh little details are
available so it's easy to kind of Cobble
together a superficially plausible Story
and there's this trade-off between
probability and plausibility you add
more details which you can glean from
the internet your story becomes in a way
more plausible the same way this Senator
thing but less probable and um you know
if you're a vulner if you're available
to begin with and you have all these
seemingly uh precise details
you can call people
and a lot of this what we're talking
about is is not maybe what I would
necessarily think of as a math in the
traditional math curriculum so so much
is Just logic and and clear thinking do
you distinguish between these two things
or is it all one set of sensible
thoughts to you
uh
yes it is possible to distinguish I mean
it is a matter of clear thinking but
yeah there are other components in fact
I mean one thing I've tried to do in my
writing is kind of set up a links
between stories and statistics or
narratives and numbers whatever even in
my first book math and humor I talked
about the similarities between uh jokes
and and uh
and uh philosophy and Mathematics by the
way there's both math and jokes depend
on logic although the logic might be
perverted the patterns might be
different but you use some of the same
tools we took to you out of certain uh
for different reasons and humor and
jokes is for the absurdum and math it's
disprove something but but there is a
kind of Continuum and in the in the
Continuum between math and jokes is
puzzles they're they're more substantial
than jokes but they they do share with
math also this aha moment and uh so in
essence uh puzzles are very mathematical
and uh whether they're mechanical
puzzles like Rubik's Cube and other
group Theory and that or any or verbal
puzzles like get money home so uh you
know there are similarities but uh I
mean there are you know so it is kind of
a Continuum there's not a Chasm between
here's numbers and here's narratives
there's a connection I mean there's
differences one is that in mathematics
or science the logic is extensional if
you have a proof or something every
every time you have a three you could
put in square root of nine or cube root
of 27 it doesn't make a difference but
you can't just a woman can't just say or
a man can't just say ah the happiest day
of my life was the 80th anniversary of
uh 110th anniversary of Miller
Fillmore's death even if that even if
that was her when it was the day yeah
what was the day but you you know are
you crazy that the happy anniversary is
the 110th anniversary so you you can't
do that and also just the whole kind of
psychological mindset that you know when
you do reading a story science fiction
or whatever just uh for the enjoyment
you suspend this belief
okay let's go with it but in math or
science or statistics she's just the
opposite you suspend beliefs so you're
not Bamboozled you want to really prove
it so there are lots of differences and
but uh but still they're both human
Endeavors and they're they're not the
totally distinct things uh storytelling
and and Theorem proving or number
crunching well you have the word
narrative right there in the title of
the new book so it's clear that that you
recognize that and I guess it is
interesting how human beings we use math
but we love stories I recently did a
podcast with Peter Dodds who is a
statistician complex system theorists uh
who who made a quote that I will never
stop quoting which is never bring
statistics to a story fight
people love their stories and I guess
maybe I don't know how it you know
intentional it is or it just seemed to
be the best way to do it but what you're
doing in your books is telling people
math and helping them learn math through
the device of fun little stories
exactly I like to use uh
jokes puzzles anecdotes uh little
vignettes and you can often get the the
math across without arousing people's
kind of too many people's uh and they uh
if not fear discomfort with numbers or
fear they're going to be judged but you
get the same idea of course without the
formalism
I mean there's a limit to it you can't
but uh but you can get a good deal of
mathematics across with um with stories
in fact uh uh one of my books I think
therefore I laugh I I was based I was
inspired by a quote by Wittgenstein who
said you could write a good and serious
book in philosophy that consisted
entirely of jokes or jokes where joke is
interpreted very Loosely very Loosely
get the joke you get the relevant
philosophical point
and uh so the concede in the book is you
know here's a collection of stories
jokes anecdotes that uh get points
across well I'll confess I have not
actually read your books that discuss
math and humor but I now that you
brought up the idea I'm fascinated by
the concept of a Continuum between math
and jokes and it does make sense that
there's this aha moment right I mean a
joke is somehow confounding our
expectations somehow and a math puzzle
is somehow resisting immediate analysis
uh has there been I don't know academic
work on the relationship between these
two things uh not too much uh there are
a couple of journals of humor that kind
of touch on it but uh I mean I think
that's one of the appeal of
counter-intuitive results in math
they're kind of like
jokes like what you can't do that it's
continuous but not differentiables
[Laughter]
and so I
I even even in this book I bring up some
philosophical issues uh about the Eugene
vickner and unreasonable Effectiveness
in mathematics narratives is a
collection of metaphors
adjusted by true belief is not equally
knowledge and
um
so
I can tell that you had some
philosophical background as well as the
usual mathematical background
yeah as an undergraduate I skipped
around I majored for a while in
philosophy and in English and physics I
kept coming back to math but uh I always
wanted to write so in a sense I I do
both yeah the right got the exactly the
right thing so a lot of the examples
we've been talking about here are either
logic or probability
um there's a lot more to math than that
obviously if you were put in charge if
you were the Emperor of math education
now what what is it that you would say
people should learn what is the minimum
basic knowledge of math that one has to
be numerate
well a facility with arithmetic first of
all and um and uh of course probability
and uh and the logic and Notions in the
philosophy of science I mean just uh
everyday Notions like what's the placebo
what's the double-blind study uh which
you know most people are innocent of in
fact I just wrote a piece for three
parts daily about uh uh why uh quizzes
for Congressional aspirants I mean at
any time you apply for a job especially
a high-tech job you you are interviewed
and they give you some problems can you
program this in python or whatever but
yet you can run for uh you know Congress
uh you can run for president and uh
you know there's no such
uh test and uh perhaps there should be
although you'd have to Dragoon people
into it or shame them into it but you
wouldn't have Herschel Walker saying
yeah you know why are we making clean
air we just send it to China and they
send us dirty air and uh
Evolutions The hoax and uh it's kind of
embarrassing I do want to I want to um
you know note your your mention of three
quarks daily that's one of our favorite
websites here at the winescape podcast
so I'm glad that you put in a plug for
that oh yeah no I I I enjoy it as well
but the fact that I write a kind of
semi-regular column for them but but
let's take seriously this somewhat
provocative idea that we should have
standards for politicians or leaders or
something like that
um and we should have standards but it's
very hard to get it right I mean we for
various reasons and and my ask me
anything episodes of the podcast I
recently revealed my uh love as a high
school kid for reading Robert Heinlein
novels and Heinlein once said that you
know you shouldn't be allowed to vote if
you can't solve a quadratic equation
and that it seems a bit extreme to me
like I I mean I I understand the the
motivation but uh should should
politicians be allowed to run for office
if they can't solve a quadratic equation
uh yeah I think that's a bad example but
uh being able to uh having some feel for
like scaling like we can't scale up
things like every time I go to the movie
I'm always amazed so you can get a uh
you know a soda that's eight inches high
or 10 inches high and a 10 inch high one
is 50 Cents more than eight inch might
one even though it's probably uh you
know what uh the volume is much greater
or ordering a pizza so I mean scale of
people don't realize that things scale
up
squares or cubes geometric things but
even uh you know size of cities scale up
in with the fractional exponent job free
rest West uh talked about that I talked
about that so it's um it's a kind of
basic notion uh that uh I think some
people should have some idea about as as
well as being able to estimate things
I'm just a very rough estimate you get
help somebody uh Empire State Building
is Two Mile High two miles high and you
don't have to know the exact height that
happens to be 1776 feet but uh two miles
high and you really realize that
some appreciation for a normal uh you
know estimates I mean even if you ask
people
um you know there's a study that's done
that that 42 percent of heart attacks
occur on Friday Saturday and Sunday and
people attribute this to heavy drinking
and partying so and you know I can see
people saying wow I better be careful uh
but Friday Saturday and Sunday is three
sevenths of a week which is 43 percent
so um I mean the same thing at four day
holiday weekend the 400 people are gonna
die
35 000 or more a year do die on the
highway
so it's a normal four days it's not like
that so there's some feeling for
Relevant magnitudes for
for um
scalene for estimating for sequencing
some things you have to do in a certain
order lots of little puzzles like that
and those don't involve quadratic
equations uh which you know I don't
think that would be a reasonable
requirement no it's just memorizing a
formula yeah I do get that but it it's
interesting because all the examples
you're giving
um are a little bit different than what
we actually teach people in high school
right or even in college like we take
geometry and trigonometry maybe calculus
and and I love all these subjects dearly
but as far as I know at least when I was
in high school we didn't take
probability statistics scaling estimates
uh any anything like that are you are
you implicitly suggesting a radical
revision of the secondary school math
curriculum uh well I mean it's hard to
generalize because some schools I think
uh do and the best schools do but uh
I don't know about a radical revision
but certainly an addition of uh such
topics that that are most relevant to uh
politics popular culture and everyday
life I I think you know scaling as I
said
uh estimation and so on and and just an
ability to kind of think outside the box
one thing I I talk about in an argument
uh uh so uh all right
anti-anti-abortionist that uh is you
know is is kind of fanciful but it is
interesting that people who are absolute
super absolutists with regard to Banning
abortion I think that you could it would
be useful to kind of uh get them to
admit that in certain cases I'm not
talking about rape for instance but in
certain regular cases they should have
abortion should be there and there's a
story I like that I prefaced abortion
story with about George Bernard Shaw
supposedly and again the story might be
apocryphaly sitting next to a woman at
this Posh dinner party and he said would
you sleep with me for a million pounds
and she says uh yes I will and she
laughs and giggles and then she's then
he said would you sleep with me for 10
pounds and she says no what do you who
do you think I am and he says well we
already established that now we're just
haggling a bunch of details but you know
it's a stupid story sexist story but
it's relevant to uh this argument I'm
gonna make imagine uh that
um because of some Cosmic catastrophe or
toxins and the environment or whatever
that women who became pregnant became
pregnant with 10 to 20 fetuses
that's one assumption and two I imagine
that advances in uh in technology and uh
worth the procedures and neonatal
technology
enabled doctors to save some or all of
the fetuses if they intervene in the
first three months so if that's the case
uh what would people who are absolutist
opponents of abortion do
uh if people got a woman got pregnant
with 10 or 20 fetuses they can't just
say well we'll take some of them and let
the other ones go because that's 10
amounts of abortion and uh so they'd
have to uh to be maintain their position
they'd have to accept a 10 to 20 fold
increase in uh birth rates which I think
they wouldn't do and um so again just to
get away from the absolutist position
and the relevance of that today uh so he
uh George Menard Shaw's story is once
you get them off of this totally
absolute disposition then the rest is
haggling about the details you can go
for 15 weeks or 20 weeks or whatever
so um
in any case I think yeah the the concept
that the kinds of math that we teach
people in high school or whatever I I
really think that's something we should
take much more seriously you know I I
myself when it comes to science often
complain that we teach science as a list
of facts right a list of true things
rather than as the process the empirical
hypothesis testing process which is much
more Central to it and people come out
not really
understanding what to do with news
stories about science in the media and I
guess probably the same thing is true
with math also that there's different
kind of math that is equally good that
would be way more relevant to people's
reasoning in everyday circumstances
yeah I think that's true except uh in a
case of physics or science in general
those stories do make it into popular
press whereas there's very rare that any
breakthrough in uh or big results in
mathematics will be written about
uh but uh no but I I agree but I I think
it should be part of a a general you
know I mean general knowledge is is
important as well and uh and it's it's
you know and teaching weariness
skepticism uh suspending belief and so
on it is important and it's connected to
a lot of things I mean uh I it's
interesting I I write about uh people
who are most uh Pro free enterprise have
no problem accepting the complexity of
an economy and they don't say wow how do
they come into being all of a sudden but
it does you can go to any store in the
country any convenience store and you
can get a Snickers bar or a half a
gallon of milk and you can get any kind
of clothes or shoes anywhere you want
and nobody said how did this come into
and to beings immediately but yet they
make this for some people make their own
intelligent design people so-called make
the same make the comparable argument
they look at it came how did Life come
into into being so immediately how did
this lie come into being instead of
saying well to use the the the
verboten word it evolved the same way
cities cities and economy evolved but
they uh the most accepting of capitalism
and which and least accepting of the
analogous process when it comes to life
and uh so yeah I mean I guess this is a
common theme of what you're saying is
it's not just clear thinking but a
consistency of thinking across domains
and people always talk about we should
teach critical thinking or something
like that I I I actually I don't know
whether or not that makes sense is that
something that can be taught in your
experience
uh to some extent I mean there it does
often devolve into something kind of
silly
but uh I mean I think uh getting people
to know a lot not just the X but Trends
and connections between disparate Fields
like uh you know
economics and um
and uh evolution is I mean if you if you
know something not a lot necessarily I
mean it helps if you know a lot but you
know something and and are taught to
bring bring things together to try to
relate to have a kind of more holistic
uh attitude towards knowledge I think
that's uh that's a worth worthwhile
Endeavor but you're right I mean it's
hard I'm not sure how how you go about
teaching critical thinking because
people always are gone me on to some
fact the key and the key formula the key
thing yeah and um
often there is no clear thing well and
often it's a sort of against their
interest right people don't want to
reach certain conclusions and the human
brain is really really good at reaching
the conclusions we want to reach not the
ones that the data are forcing us to go
toward yeah exactly
yeah I talk a lot about logical logic in
the while you're coming I mean even in
the stock market there's efficient
market hypothesis says that you know
information about a stock is immediately
available to everybody
uh but it it most markets aren't all
that efficient but it's you can it have
a great a kind of relevant example a
relevant uh something that's relevant to
the uh
Liars Paradox in the fishing Market
hypothesis is true to the effect that
most people think it's not true
because if most people think it's not
true
uh then they'll say oh and there you
know there's a a way I can make more
money and they'll
do all kinds of contortions research
that and by doing that they'll make it
efficient and if they already think it's
efficient
uh then that's what's the word what's
the what's the worth of doing that
that's every information every bit of
information is already priced in or what
do I want to do that for so um
a lot of these paradoxes are relevant to
broader themes and again that to your
point that it's generally not thought in
a math class it's hard there in any
class so you kind of have to come upon
it yourself or
or uh whatever I'll read who's counting
yeah exactly read who's counting uh
speaking of which this is a perfect
segue because I wanted to shift gears a
little bit
um you have the new book out I have a
new book that recently came out that
also uh well I wanted to contrast it a
little bit because my in my new book the
biggest ideas in the universe uh I try
to teach people the basics of classical
physics the difference being from other
books that I do the math that I show
them all the equations there's over 100
equations in the book all the way up to
Einstein's equation and so one of the
angles I try out when I come across a
skeptic is who says you know I just
don't understand equations I will never
be able to understand it and I say look
you understand two plus two equals four
that's an equation right and it's a
matter of degree not of kind to
understand Einstein's equation it's just
a little bit more complicated there's no
such thing as people who can't
understand equations it's just you know
are you willing to do a little bit more
work than you usually do so what do you
think of that of that angle is that a
plausible story
I think so I I think uh you know if
Stephen Hawking allegedly uh
uh said that uh if you put an equation
in your book you cut the readership by
you by a uh a half so if you put 100
very very tiny
but I think that's false I mean uh but
uh yeah you just have to have to do it
uh carefully I mean you have to embed
the equation uh in a discussion in which
it makes sense and you can't just barely
say there's there's formulas
but uh I I think that's you know that's
you know so I I think that's a good idea
if you I I'm sure you did yeah I've read
some of yours so if you you do write
very well and it is embedded in a
context that gives it meaning
well we tried but I'm wondering about
the level of abstraction right I mean
now that I've done this experiment I'm
curious to see if other people enjoy it
or not but when you talk about
Einstein's equation for general
relativity you know not equals mc
squared but R mu Nu minus one half RGB
new uh that is there's some Journey that
the learner has to go on to to Really
wrap their heads around it and and I'm
just I'm wondering if it is really
something that you know some people just
aren't going to do or aren't willing to
do or is it could we teach everybody
Einstein's equation and that those other
kinds of higher math that we're
certainly not going to do in high school
I think uh you could reach a lot of
people I I wouldn't say everybody but uh
you could reach many more people than I
reach now
because uh if it was uh done right yeah
given the opportunity
yeah given the opportunity requiring
your book exactly there you go we're
fishing for that one but yes but I mean
actually let's start go ahead no I was
just going to say I mean two and two
equals four is always put forth as a
kind of standard uh
simple fact but uh but everything is
depends on context I mean it's not
always the case if you take uh two cups
of popcorn and add two cups of water to
it you get three cups of soggy popcorn
not not four so and that's I mean so any
bit of mathematics can be misapplied
here's the story of the the uh bear
hunters who became extinct shortly after
they mastered Vector analysis because
before they had mastered Vector analysis
when they saw a bear to the Northwest
they shot it but now that they know
Vector analysis they see a bear to the
Northwest they shoot one arrow to the
north and one arrow to the west and the
bear gets old
so in math like adding the integers and
simple Vector analysis this silliness is
is clear as apparent but if you get into
more complex mathematics you can say
something equally stupid and um and but
it goes by it's very easy to intimidate
people if you if you're a mathematician
or a physicist because people aren't
going to challenge you you can say the
most abstro sounding nonsense
well this is the famous anxiety people
have when they take math classes about
word problems right like you can
memorize how to manipulate the equations
and maybe get the right answer but if
you need to translate from words into
equations that's harder but in some
sense that's by far the more important
skill right that goes back to my
narrative numbers continue yeah
and and that is by far more important
you mentioned already uh the phrase the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics and of course the what the
unreal the unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics and physics which is a
famous phrase from Eugene vigner uh
which by the way I'm a little skeptical
that it's true that it's unreasonably
effective I kind of think that no matter
what physics turned out to be we would
find math for it after the fact
right I I'm very skeptical of it because
we learn about numbers by playing with
little Pebbles and putting them together
you take this one or that one that's
addition learn about geometry by looking
at uh little twigs and extending them
and making little triangles on them and
uh also we learn about physics by our
working through the walking through the
world so mathematics is kind of an
idealization an abstraction of everyday
things that that we do so I I I don't
think it's all that unreasonable if you
abstract if you to idealize what you do
when you're playing with pebbles and
twigs and and moving around it's not
surprising you get a mathematics that's
going to be effective it grew out of
things that that work
but there then there are some that's a
great that's another great sideway
because I I've been recently thinking in
part because I had a podcast interview
with Justin Clark Doan who is a
philosopher of mathematics so I've been
thinking about the foundations of
mathematics and mathematical logic and
it is the part of math that I understand
the least I really really struggle like
geometry and topology I can do but when
you get into proving relationships
between models and Axiom systems and
things like that I I I just really
really struggle with it but am I correct
that that's part of that was part of
your uh mathematical research
yeah yeah I uh my degree was in PhD in
mathematics but I was most interested in
my thesis and papers were in logic in
model Theory and non-standard Logics and
uh yeah I was interested as I said as an
undergraduate in philosophy and that's
still kind of a mathematic studying you
know at least initially was most
interested in and I talk about girls
there about an on standard proof of it
using ideas from complexity Theory Greg
Greg Chapin and um
yeah so I I think a little bit of some
logic doesn't have to be you know go too
far but um
people don't know the difference being
you know affirming the consequence and
all these selecting terms and uh I think
they they should they don't they
probably just focus on memorizing the
terms instead of understanding them but
can you say more about proving girdle's
theorem using complexity Theory yeah a
sequence is
is random if the the shortest program
that generates it is about as as long as
as the sequence itself and it's not
random if you can generate I mean zero
one zero one zero one you can generate
that by just saying zero one repeated
right a thousand times but um you can
never generate something more complex
than the generating algorithm and uh so
it uses that and varies Paradox to show
that uh you know you can't speak Loosely
you can't generate 10 pounds of theorems
from five pounds of axioms there's
always going to be there is there a
statements that you're not going to be
able to prove it because of the limited
complexity of any logical system a nice
example it's kind of silly but I like uh
very Paradox as uh you're in an elevator
you're very short the building is very
tall press the first button that you
can't reach
so it's um yeah I sketched a little bit
more than that but uh I I like the the
uh Jaden proof of girls theorem uh
better because it it it's connected to a
more basic stuff about the notion of
complexity complexity is something
that's in the world and it's an
important topic in computer science and
uh from it follow us uh girl in
completeness in without going through
when looking at girl numbers and so on
no that's that's fascinating I didn't
really uh know about it so just to make
sure I get it right I mean girdle's
theorem is saying that if you have a
system that you assume is consistent
which you can't prove right but if you
assume it's consistent there's roughly
speaking going to always be statements
that are true but unprovable in that
system
neither yeah neither approval nor of
disprovable right right just undecided
and undecidable exactly and so what
you're saying is that that kind of
follows from a counting argument that
you you can just yeah imagine that
there's
I don't quite see the argument but I get
that that it could be there that uh
given a finite axiomatic system you can
only reach so many provable statements
and there's a lot more out there that
are neither provable nor disprovable
right beyond our r or the systems
complexity Horizon
and is that kind of higher level
abstract mathematics also useful to
people on the street you know beyond
conditional probabilities and things
like that or these sort of Wilder Realms
of mathematics uh also rewarding
uh rewarding but uh I'm not sure be
useful to too many people on the street
they'd have to have a kind of
theoretical event I guess but Computer
Sciences is uh
you know a big part of it is about uh
classifying sets to add coding for their
complexity and getting algorithms that
are harder and harder to break not
necessarily
a Quantum uh algorithms but the just
regular ones involving you know prime
numbers and simple facts about the
number Theory right but uh so in essence
I mean they're important I mean there
there's uh GH Hardy mathematician I once
wrote a book called a mathematician's
apology in which case he uh said he only
pure method only number Theory pure
numbers is the only thing that's that's
worth our reverence and the uh you know
Applied Mathematics he acted like his
pornography or something
but actually somebody once wrote a
review of his book one one sentence
review of G.H Hardy's
apology and he said uh the world sickens
from such cloistered clowning
the funny thing is that number Theory uh
which she thought was so pure I mean you
couldn't carry on a modern economy
without being able to transfer trillions
of dollars over oceans and around the
world instantaneously so this um some
even number theory was uh it was very
applied you can't tell what's applied
and the same thing relativity and
Mankowski Riemann and so on and they
weren't talking about physics but the
constructed the tools it's also
fascinating to me how people get worked
up about these mathematical issues I was
I was just reading
um a little bit about Georg contour and
his proof of the different kinds of
infinity and how I guess Leopold
chronicer really gave him a hard time
like really just tried to ruin his
career because he had proven that there
were different kinds of infinity yeah
right
yeah there's only the integers and
everything else is uh yeah it's made up
I kind of I I've been wondering again
for for research level reasons do we
really need infinity or do we really
need a continuous infinity or could we
just imagine that reality just works on
either a finite or at least a countable
set of things and and we're sort of kind
of just amusing ourselves but not really
making productive understanding of the
universe by thinking about all these
more difficult levels of infinity that's
a good question I I don't know I mean
it's a very beautiful subject uh
trans-finite arithmetic and trans-finite
set theory in general
but um
I I don't know if
by the way one thing about chronica he
said only the integers exist but there's
you know lots of connections between the
two but one that I find And discussing
the book about is that the number e
2.718 and so on which is plays a big
role in math
Finance everything else all kinds of
instances but this one I like you tell
people look at their computer or phone
and randomly pick a real number between
zero and a thousand okay you have to
pick rational if you're doing it with a
computer but still it's close enough so
pick a real number between zero and a
thousand then keep on doing that until
the sum of the real numbers you picked
is over one thousand
okay so I need to pick 502 308 uh 607
the third number would be over so if you
have a whole you know many many people
or do this or you do it yourself many
many times the average number of numbers
you have to choose before you get a sum
over a thousand is e
[Laughter]
yeah so that's weird I mean there's so
Chronicle was even his uh beloved just
integers positive integers give us rise
to the number e which is irrational
transcendental and so on it is yeah I I
get that it's hard to get around the
appearance of these numbers you know one
of my favorite blog posts I ever wrote
was on Pi Day you know Pi Day March 14th
which is also Einstein's birthday and so
I wrote about the fact that in
Einstein's equation we were just talking
about the one for general relativity the
right hand side is 8 Pi g t mu Nu and so
Pi appears there in the in the equation
for gravity and why is that and you know
it's a very interesting story having to
do with the fact that spheres have Pi in
them when you calculate the area of a
sphere and Isaac Newton gave us a law
for forces rather than for Fields so all
these numbers are there yeah maybe maybe
that's a good reason not to try to
discretize the world too much yeah no I
think you can I mean actually look at
the ramanujan the famous Indian
mathematician who died early he has he
came up with also towards the crazy
identity he said that involve pi and E
and infinite sums and uh and you say how
did he ever come
for that and uh we did nobody I mean
G.H Hardy writes about him he said he
was the only I'm paraphrasing it but the
only person he ever loved uh
platonically is uh well for him it would
be uh was ramanujan I mean he just fell
in love with the you know the amazing
kind of resonance that reminiscent had
with the mathematical universe yeah
Robin and Jones is a great example
almost as a counter example but as a
version of this this idea that I like to
to mention that the human brain is not
meant to do math uh we have to train
ourselves right you know we're meant to
make Rough and Ready things Rough and
Ready estimates but not so much more
precise calculations but not all brains
are equal at it and he is an example of
someone who really did in a way that no
one understands seemed to just see
things out there in the world of of the
natural numbers and the continued
fractions and things like that that were
pretty amazing
it is and in and to this day
incomprehensibly
like how did he come to this yes and I
often he he didn't he didn't necessarily
believe in proofs I mean Hardy had a he
came from India and Hardy to give him
some conventional mathematics where we
prove things and he often just intuited
it in some sense and uh so a lot of his
amazing results are just statements and
then people mathematicians work fevers
oh yeah
it makes you wonder do you have feelings
about the future of artificial
intelligence as mathematical proof
generator it could be could we get a lot
more proofs for theorems once the AIS
really get good at it
I think so yeah I it's hard to make uh
predictions but uh
yeah I I think so and not just
mathematics I mean every day uh life
every day humans sometimes I fear
um
and yeah I do want to give you a chance
to there was one little piece of
advanced math that appeared in the book
that I thought was very amusing and I
would like to understand better myself
so you know it's getting late in the
podcast we can you can indulge ourselves
a little bit which is Ramsay Theory you
use it as an example of how complexity
appears in unexpected places so I'll
give you a chance to explain that a
little bit now Ramsey theory is just the
idea that with a big enough set and a
big enough number of connections among
the elements you're gonna necessarily
have some bit of order the order is
going to going to be there if you if you
have six six points uh and you connect
them with with lines six nodes you
connect them with lines there's
necessarily going to be some of them
with blue line some of them with red
lines there's necessarily going to be a
triangle where all
are the same and the results of that
sort and with bigger sets you need uh
you need a much bigger set to have you
know more order but it's impossible to
to uh not have any bit of order
in fact I mean in general that's an idea
I've always liked that uh the uh the
impossibility of total disorder because
if you if you have total disorders on a
higher level in a sense those ordered I
mean that's uh statistical mechanics I
mean disorder and then at the higher
level you get that you get a definition
of temperature which is more macro and
and there are other elements like
talking in you connect the light bulbs
in some random way on and off and if you
have some rule if two of the three
inputs are on it'll go on or off and no
matter how uh kind of random you make
the rules after a while you get some
header and it keeps appearing and that
means it's and like the game of of life
I mean again these random things become
computers and wolfram's work and and uh
and uh Conway's uh life life game and so
on so an order arises no matter what
which I find an intriguing kind of
result in a kind of generalized sort of
way yeah I'll confess I don't completely
understand it myself I would love to
understand this better because I do know
there are these examples which are very
provocative like like you just said of
uh orderliness emerging emergent is the
word that I would that I would like to
use out of the underlying lack of order
but I don't understand how robust it is
is it inevitable does it always happen
or are we cherry-picking examples where
it happens and I'm just not really sure
I I think you know again I'm just
talking off the top of my head here but
I think it always happens it just uh
maybe it takes takes longer in some
cases but um
which is kind of a unique result oh it's
very very important if it's true yeah
that's why I don't know it would be nice
to have a I don't know there's probably
other people who do know much more than
I do about that but yeah yeah but okay
so good we've we've indulged ourselves a
little bit of uh less practical
mathematical speculation but to bring it
back to to close things up
um you know you've done an enormous
amount for spreading the word of
mathematics as it were to a broad set of
people and I'm sure
in various ways large and small you've
gotten pushback about is this elitist is
it paternalistic you know are you just
getting annoying people for letting them
uh for making them not just get on with
their lives and thinking about all this
abstract stuff so how do we get people
excited and interested and educated
about math in a way that doesn't come
across as elitist and paternalistic
um
I don't know I
I don't think uh elitism is part of it I
don't see why here's some interesting
stuff it's relevant to some stuff you
might be interested in here's how it
works why that's uh viewed as a legalist
I mean of course uh it it is by a lot of
people I mean it's one of the uh one of
the reasons for uh Trump I mean
resentment drives a lot of his in his
base
uh but I don't I don't buy it I mean
just because somebody feels like that
that but you know presenting mathematics
presenting physics presenting history I
mean looking at something seriously
trying to understand it relating it to
other things I I that's not elitist that
that's human
well and maybe not to present this as a
leading answer but I think that
Being Human Being warm being engaging
being likable is is probably goes a
longer way toward making the math uh
palatable than we want to admit it's not
all just about the math we're still
human beings at the end of the day oh
yeah yeah right I mean
I mean very downward
ly on the knuckles
and tell them to go sit in a corner with
a dunce cap yeah you're not that that's
not a way to get them to uh appreciate
or love mathematics physics history I
mean but yeah you're right I I mean I
think it's it's easier to learn from uh
from a professor or from anybody if you
in a sense like them uh r10 kind of map
yourself onto them in some way I mean if
the person who's enlightening you to use
that term is kind of repellent uh you're
not going to want to learn much from
that person you did mention in passing
um that big stories in physics get more
play in the news or in science than big
stories in math do uh do you think
that's changing do you think that
there's more and better math Outreach
and and uh public engagement today than
there was 50 years ago
I think there is but uh and science is
something that people understand I mean
they don't understand the details but
they know that the moon's up there and
uh and the universe is expanding and
life goes as fast and uh and you know
and even just uh speculative theories uh
Multiverse and so on uh that's something
that engages people's uh uh imagination
and so there can be more stories about
uh advances in physics or science or
biology as well whereas math I mean you
get a new result and
consequence of actually my choice or
a monarch theorem you can take a part of
the sphere and put it together make it
twice as large right I mean it strikes
people as just you know let's just hope
is focus that's you know mathematicians
you know whatever so I mean they're
they're but but as far as Outreach in
general I mean I think stem is more
widely uh
understood is what is why it's important
and again it's hard to generalize about
pedagogy but more more places do a good
job even though they're still a vast
number of people who are innumerate feel
like they were better done but there is
no better determine there's no better
term and there's no better person who's
done more to combat it than you have so
John Allen polos thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast uh thanks
very much Sean I truly enjoyed it
[Music]